Hey korra nation it's Charlie and Nick just
posted an official trailer for the Legend
of Korra so I'm going to do a full breakdown
of that.
A lot of you sent me links for the leaked
episodes.
I'm not going to repost them so please don't
post any pirate links in the comments.
I will explain why the leak happened and do
some non-spoilery commentary on the episodes.
I'm not going to review them, just because
it wouldn't be fair given the video quality
was bad and they were Chilean dubs with english
subs re-translated, so a lot of the dialogue
was wrong.
It was a whole big thing but I'll explain
after the trailer breakdown.
If you're finding me for the first time I
do a ton of Korra videos, mostly when episodes
are airing.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'm going to be doing bonus videos on a weekly
basis now that we have our first trailer and
they'll be airing episodes soon.
Those videos will probably be on Fridays or
Saturdays.
Here we go, this breakdown will just be shot
for shot through the trailer.
There's no dialogue in it, but it's enough
to gage what some of the character relationships
and locations are.
First off, the new title sequence looks beautiful.
We see korra staring at Ba Sing Se, confirming
that the Earth Kingdom is a big part of the
story.
Then we see what looks like a city made of
metal, which makes some sense given that metal
bending has evolved to a much more sophisticated
art form since Toph started training people.
We see Korra training with one of the new
characters, we don't know her name but she's
dressed in Earth Kingdom clothing so she's
might be one of a couple new core members
of Team Avatar.
Shout out for the Sky Bison we saw during
Book 2.
Airbending is a much bigger part of Book 3,
so it's only natural that we'd see a giant
herd of sky bison.
Speaking of which, here's a better shot at
some of the new airbender disciples which
moves directly to Tenzin surveying an airbender
temple in the distance.
We see someone sitting in prison implying
that that long shot was actually tenzin staring
at an airbender jail.
Or a temple being used as a jail.
I think this next shot is just a follow up
on the metal bending city we saw earlier with
the airships.
Everyone is wearing metal plating and that
tower looks like it's also made of metal.
Here is where things get interesting, this
is back in republic city as we can see from
Lin's Police Force.
That looks like Mako they're trying to arrest.
But why is he on top of a bridge?
Maybe he jumped off one of Asami's airships.
Otherwise he would have had to climb up there.
So this next shot is a pretty big deal, this
is Bumi stopping a ball of air using airbending.
Which yes, doesn't make sense, but what I've
heard is that Harmonic Convergence in Book
2 and the new spiritual balance between realms
make all benders more powerful and turn some
non-benders from bending families into benders.
Like Bumi for instance, normally being the
son of an avatar you'd expect him to be a
very powerful bender, but because the world
was out of spiritual alignment during Aang's
time, bending in general was much less prevalent.
It's an example of how things from Book 2
will have consequences in Book 3 and 4.
I really like the idea of them paying off
things like that.
Moving along, it looks like where at another
prison in the Water Tribe.
This person looks like she has the same abilities
as Combustion Man.
She might be related to him or just have randomly
developed the ability from birth.
She definitely looks like she's being held
in prison too.
This looks like another villain being kept
in a prison, we can't see his face so there
isn't much context yet.
This looks like the female water bender villain
everyone was talking about earlier this year.
We're seeing different types of benders in
prison, so it looks like the main villains
will be a group of different benders being
held separately based on their abilities.
Everybody cheer, because the water bending
twins are back and it looks like they're helping
Tonraq and Zuko, one more cheer.
We saw Zuko in that leaked trailer a couple
of months ago, so it's not a huge surprise
that he's in this trailer.
This is one of the other new recurring characters
that will work with Team Avatar, it looks
like they'll be meeting him when they travel
to Ba Sing Se.
Here we actually get a better look at the
tattooed man doing those pullups.
It looks like he's chasing down Mako and Bolin.
It looks like the place there in is directly
on top of a lava flow.
Here's a shot of Zuko riding his dragon.
This was actually part of the footage in that
old leaked trailer but this is nice and shiny
HD footage.
More white lotus members chasing one of the
villains down.
This person has a lot of similar features
to Lin Beifong, so it might be a relative.
Were supposed to meet a lot of Beifong's family
in Book 3.
This is a much better shot of the earth kingdom
person korra was practicing airbending with.
It looks like she's part of Lin's police force
in republic city.
Here's Kya looking like a badass taking down
this airbender in the distance.
I know a lot of you were asking me if she
was going to be in book 3 and now it's confirmed.
And she does way more than just heal people.
Asami is looking pretty badass, taking down
someone from the earth kingdom.
Here's some much better context for that airbender
jail I was talking about earlier.
It looks like this guy is one of the villains
that the white lotus is holding.
All of you Korsami shippers will go nuts this
season, it looks like Korra and Asami are
going to be spending some quality time together.
Here's the first shot of Lin in the trailer,
she's staring at that Metal Bending city.
That might be the academy created by toph
or just a fortress.
Lin is a huge part of book 3 and I'm super
excited to learn more about her past.
Spirit form Jinora.
It looks like she's using the spirit world
as a way to investigate an underground cave.
This is the first shot we've seen of Opal,
the Earth Queen, she is the daughter of the
earth king from last airbender and it looks
like she might not be super best friends with
team avatar even if she's not part of the
villains.
Bad things always seem to happen to avatars
who go to Ba Sing Se.
This actually looks like people training in
the metal bending academy.
Here's Bolin running from that earlier explosion.
A lot of these trailer scenes are just taken
from the same moments and spread out in this
trailer.
Here's that airbender villain that Kya was
yanking out of the air with her waterbending.
Zuko looks like he's working with the white
lotus and it's probably something to do with
all these villains in the different jails.
Metal Bending Korra for the win.
I can't remember the last time I saw her metalbend.
Here we see that the Dai Li are back and capturing
Jinora, despite the fact the Earth King disbanded
them during Last Airbender.
Here's that new airbender character again.
He looks like he might have a fun time with
team avatar when they first meet.
Kind of like when we first met toph as a child
and she was't the friendliest person.
This is one of my favorite shots in the trailer,
Korra is using her airbending to sail a desert
ship away from the Jaws of Sand Sharks.
Beifong in training, there isn't a lot of
context, but there's got to be something happening
in the earth kingdom that's going to bring
her back.
I'm guessing that will be part of the Dai
Li plot and the white lotus villain plot will
be a totally different story.
This is mako fighting that evil waterbender,
there's some scenes from later in the trailer
too.
Here's the first real shot of a spirit whale
floating around in the physical realm.
Remember at the end of last season, spirits
started to come back into the physical realm,
but this is the first shot of one in the trailer.
So here the action just builds into a series
of different fight scenes all with that group
of villains the white lotus and zuko were
trying to deal with.
This final shot is just a callback to all
the spirit vines growing in republic city
last year.
And that's it, just for reference about 50%
of that footage was what was in those leaked
episodes.
So it was really cool of them to release more
new stuff.
Not just recycle the leaked footage.
The picture it generally paints is that there
will be a team of villains made up of different
types of benders that the white lotus and
Zuko will be dealing with.
That will probably be the main threat, then
there's the earth kingdom plot, the earth
queen and the Dai Li.
That will probably be the B story, the one
that will feature Beifong, Jinora and the
other side characters.
The didn't add a release date for the episodes
in the trailer, but the first book 2 trailer
came about two months before the book 2 premiere.
So this could mean Nick is going to start
airing episodes in august.
The other possibility is that because of the
leak, they'll air them starting in July.
We'll have to wait and see.
Until episodes start airing, I'll just be
doing weekly bonus videos.
But when episodes get here I'll do review
videos and Q&As.
So about the leak, here's what happened.
You probably heard that the episodes were
posted by Mundo Nick on their website.
That's the mexico office for nickelodeon.
Because most people think of tv shows in terms
of seasons, they got confused because Nick
uses Books to denote different seasons of
Korra.
So they were posting book 2 episodes on their
website and mistakenly posted 4 episodes of
Book 3.
They were up for almost an entire day before
they got taken down.
They were actually chilean dubs, not spanish.
Which is kind of weird, but whatever.
The quality of the animation this season looks
amazing compared to Book 2, Studio Miir did
all the episodes, but the story plotting and
character development is much much better
than book 2, so I think overall.
these new episodes will be the best Korra
you guys have ever seen.
Now it's your turn though, let me know what
you thought of the trailer and what your theories
are about the new villains.
The cool thing is that because book 3 and
book 4 were ordered at the same time, there's
a good chance that the main villains will
be part of both.
So the story will just carry over.
My next Korra video will just be a Q&A, I'll
post that tomorrow.
So add all your questions in the comments.
Right now click here to get it.
I'll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And click here to learn about the new star
wars villain.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!